what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
oh my goodness look at these people
hello everybody so there's usually a
topic and then we dive into q a today
laura is here and so laura had the
winning question your question was one
word obstacles so why don't you tell us
a little bit first about
the obstacles you're facing and then
let's make this um let's make this
content matter
okay
well thank you so much uh you're a role
model to me so your answers and
i mean you know this this is so critical
for me so obstacles and i'm right in the
beginning of the book evan and i'm in
the middle of the first really that
finding out my who i'm still there um
and i and i'm encountering all sorts of
obstacles and i'm a
tony robbins person i have
i follow his advice on obstacles but i
still seem to be struggling with this
where
in other words i'm working on i have a
full-time job and working on a my
business that i eventually want to be my
you know my everything but i'm finding
that there are so many distractions that
they become these obstacles and i'm
having trouble getting past them
to see my outcome and this is even with
with my reading of my book and spending
time in your book and and trying to
focus
these obstacles are taking over
and i'm i'm having trouble managing the
obstacles for example parents you know
aging parents and they're very very
needy helicopter parents and i i'm
trying boundaries but this is a big
obstacle for me that's my question i
love it no and listen thank you for
thank you for showing up but thank you
for sharing and thank you for being
vulnerable that you know it's a
that's a hard thing to do so i
appreciate you for doing that some of
the obstacles are you know our our own
resistance to things and we're afraid of
we're afraid you know it's like you're
afraid of doing the thing and so we find
a way to procrastinate you know like if
you're procrastinating on something it's
because
you either don't want to do the thing
you know you don't want to read my book
you know or you're or you're afraid
you're afraid of like what it may mean
and what changes may come
um and and
the the path through procrastination is
really to figure out okay what's the
source because if it's that you really
don't want to do it then we need to find
a way to not be doing it long term
but if you
really do want to do it but you're just
afraid that the fear is not a good
enough reason anymore that we've
wrapped things up into a story that
we'll believe but really it's just fear
underneath it
fear of you launching your business fear
of it fear of it working out fear of it
not working out for the people will see
you feel the people won't see you it's
like we're afraid of both
and it's really just fear talking
there's ways around parents obviously
you can you can put away your phone you
can not have any connection to you you
want to read a book and you're afraid
about your parents cool you know go to a
park turn off your phone and go read
your book like there's there's solutions
around it but really it's identifying
what's the source of the fear if it's
building your business
what are you so afraid of
inside that company
does prevent i'm assuming that you want
to do it that the procrastination isn't
because you know somebody else is
telling you to do it
you want to do it but you're afraid to
do it what is the actual fear that's
underlying
the procrastination
the fear is that i won't be able to be
there for my family i don't actually
live with them and they're and they're
old and my great great my grandparents
are actually
getting so old they're all struggling so
that it's such a very needy situation
and um
i know that when i'm successful as i've
i've been in the past few weeks leading
up till now
i was doing so good and then all of a
sudden um i was
encountering this obstacle with my
family that i was
not being available as much that i was
so it's but it's this
perhaps that's the fear it's just not
being available and and
getting past that
that's that's the tough part yeah well
and how much of the things that they're
asking for are actually urgent versus
ones that are not really
100
not right okay right what's the zone of
their importance and and and priority
versus what's mine
and everything is urgent to them it's
been like that and i'm learning now
to change how i react uh respond to
their urgencies so it's just you
feeling comfortable with the identity of
how do i be a great daughter
or or granddaughter or you know whoever
else that you're considering caring for
how do i how do i be that person and
build my business what does that look
like
and having a little bit of clarity
around that so does
taking you know today's a thursday
afternoon it's two o'clock on the east
coast for me this taking three to five
o'clock on a thursday afternoon to grow
your business whatever that means
whether you're doing emails or writing
your book or whatever that looks like
um and you turn your phone off does that
make you a bad
you know air quotes bad daughter or bad
granddaughter
no
but is you actually getting comfortable
with that that's like hey if if i am
because when you're showing up for them
you're also not fully committed to them
because you're
thinking about the other stuff you have
to do right
right and now there's like this extra
layer of guilt and judgment that you're
they're partially the blame for you not
having more success on your dreams and
your business they're not first
but that's the story
right
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
have resentment towards them that oh now
like i lost three years of work in my
business because i had to care for them
so
it's about presence
there will be there will be true
emergencies
and so
you need to be there for true
emergencies but for most of these things
that don't matter right now
how can you create
a schedule that you're not judging it's
not it's never going to be good enough
for them
right right so we have to let go of that
but but it's like
you need to live your own life so what
is that what is a happy life for you
where you're proud of yourself that you
can be an example
you know for the people in your like you
have kids
no okay for the example for the people
around you in your life
um
and also still be proud of the
being the
the daughter and granddaughter so that
when you're with them you're with them
right
that you're not thinking about the book
you should be reading or the calls you
should be making or the videos you
should be recording that you're actually
sitting there with them because you've
you've made that happen
wow yeah
yeah thank you
it's just the fear
you know it is uh and it's almost
it's like making uh
it is making business hours perhaps
right it's like making business hours
when i am available
and not available so that i can be
available i got it mm-hmm
and and they may never fully understand
it
like they probably won't you know at
this age they probably won't so this is
where it gets tough because it becomes
now it's
your job to be the adult in the
relationship
yeah
which is right which is hard for your
parents or like grandparents
absolutely absolutely that's
that's how it's feeling it's feeling
like i'm becoming a
parent
now
okay yeah so you know in parents
um you know i have a son like you don't
want to spend all day long with your
with your kids you don't want to spend
all day long with your spouse you don't
want to spend all day long with your
grandparents you don't want to spend all
day long in your business either
and and there's the
um the
judgment as to where you should spend
time in which bucket is personal because
everybody will have an opinion on what
you should do with your life right
yeah your your mom and grandparents will
have a they'll they will have their
opinion like you need to do this laura
with your life
but it's not what you want to do
not fully it's a piece of it so what is
what does laura's version of her life
look like
and it actually allows you to show up as
a better
daughter
and granddaughter as well because you're
more present when you're with them
i mean and it's been some of that may
change like if one of them actually gets
really sick
yeah and it becomes urgent
then
now maybe you put your business goals
like if if my mom suddenly had to go to
the hospital like if she had some career
nina had to go to the hospital for
something
um
i would be okay with not being as
productive in my business
right i'm okay like that's an easy
that's an easy trade
we had a movement makers one of the only
times i missed movie makers was because
15 minutes before we were going live
nina sliced her finger open on a blender
she was trying to clean the blender and
she turned it on
and we won't go into like too much
details but like
blood everywhere and that's like i'm
about to go live like i've got my
community people are paying to be here
i'm about to go live it's like
just yelling and hear from the from the
thing right from the kitchen i come out
blood is everywhere like okay we're
going to the hospital it's like no no
i'll drive myself like are you kidding
first off like nina's amazing but you're
not driving with this with that there's
no way i'm taking you it's like what
about movement makers i don't know we'll
figure it out
so i get in the car and we start driving
i call my friend mark and say hey mark
do you have any could you talk about
clubhouse because clubhouse is popping
at the time can you come in and do a
presentation nobody's ever subbed in for
me for any of the stuff that i was doing
but can you can you please you know do
this do you have any you have anything
ready to go he said yeah i'm happy to do
it no problem um
and he ran a great show and everybody
asked some great questions and and i
wasn't allowed to go into the hospital
because of covet rules at the time so i
sat in the car and i joined in and
listened in
um but but whatever even if it didn't
work out like even if even if i had no
show you know zen who's in here was
getting the party started he's like okay
guys we're ready get ready to have evan
come on we're gonna do this thing and
then like there's mark
you know zayn evan's not there but in
the worst case i could have said
hey guys i can't make it i'm taking you
to the hospital and
some people may not have been happy with
that some people may maybe they leave
movement makers because of that maybe
they were so excited like they paid
their money and like i didn't show up
i'm okay with that trade-off right
because taking nina to the hospital to
fix now she's okay and we i still got
stitches and like no he didn't lose her
thumb or anything so it all worked out
but um
all that matters is what you feel
some people may have judged me and said
hey nope no good like i'm out cool we
may have lost some customers there um
maybe some people thought i didn't spend
enough time with her you know i don't
know but all that matters is how do i
feel about myself with how i'm showing
up for things that i care about so my
balance between being a husband and
being a father and being an entrepreneur
is my balance you don't have to be me
but you have to do you
and everybody will have their opinion on
what you should do
so it's just
getting personal clarity and spending
more time with yourself just to figure
that out like how do i show up and be a
great daughter and granddaughter and
entrepreneur what does that balance look
like
and things may throw you off but you
want the
actual emergencies like the blender and
the finger to throw you off as opposed
to
oh i don't know i'm hungry let me drop
everything and come over and make you an
outlet because you're hungry
right yeah
and
you know not to judge
you have to be the ultimate judge of
that situation right
but but you can do it
you know and they may not fully
understand it or they won't fully
understand it or support it but it's
your your life is not
being lived to make other people happy
it's to figure out what makes you happy
thank you evan that's it is the timing
of this is incredible because here i am
in the chapter what makes you happy and
you know i'm really i was sitting with
it and i rewrote it three or four times
honestly and i kept saying there's some
what is going on and it's really that
question just came to me and this was
exactly what i needed to determine
all these parts of what makes me happy
well there you go well thank you for
thank you thank you for posting it thank
you for writing the one word obstacles
and and then coming and sharing your
story we got uh susan in the house
susan's got her hand up what do we got
susan
hi evan i'm so happy to be talking to
you the last time i was on i
you you were gone before i could ask any
questions but actually
i wanna
it's i'm gonna pivot on what you were
just talking about okay
okay i'm 77 years old and
i have you know obviously
i have people i know for
a really really long time
and in this last
couple of months there's been a huge
shift in me
i'm very very different
and
a couple of people maybe more but two
people i'm thinking of right now
they're friends they're not family
they're friends
i really
reacting
they're reacting to the change
and it's negative to them well one of
them i'm actually going to see one of
the i mean one is in new york i i'm in
new york too i do see her um but
but most strikingly actually is a woman
that i'm going to be with um in florida
because there's a memorial for her
her dad's passing so i'm going to be
spending like five days with her i
haven't been with her we haven't you
know seen each other in person
in years
and we talk a lot on the phone but she's
expressed you're different i don't like
the way you've changed
there's something about you it's just so
different but the way she says it
and her irritability around it
like she's much more
nervous like she's
i don't know i feel like she's she
thinks i'm attacking her when i
i'm i'm not attack my essence is the
same you know yeah my essence is the
same my availability
is different
and i have confidence in myself for the
first time i have to say to everybody on
here and you
that i have never
felt
so in concert with myself
like i am i'm my best friend now
and i never felt that way in 70
nearly 77 years
so
i'm not in danger of anybody
i'm going to cry actually but
i'm not ending anybody taking out my
demi my light
i just don't want other people to think
that i'm jamming theirs in some way
yeah and listen so this is something
everybody goes through everybody here
can relate to it if you're on a path of
growth and development and journey as an
entrepreneur you naturally want to help
others and especially the people closest
to you like how many times you've gone
to an event and you learned something
like oh you've got to learn this thing
right and it comes from a beautiful
place the challenge is
it gets interpreted as judgment
because of their insecurity has nothing
to do with you you're giving love but
they see it as judgment because they're
insecure but where they're at they don't
like where they're at now they're
comparing themselves to you and you used
to be close in
success and now that you're doing more
and you're happier now that makes them
feel worse about yourself
so i mean as soon as he came on he's
like i love all the i love all the
papers behind you you're like you're
writing your goals out it's a healthy
routine on the board like all of these
white sheets
it's amazing all that stuff is back
there no it's great just like
susan's getting it this is fantastic
the key thing to think about there is um
you have to find a point if you want the
relation to continue
you have to find a point that you still
can connect on
and
don't worry about them
being happy for you
for the things that you're off and doing
um
i was
i was meeting with an entrepreneur
recently
and um he was going back he's having
trouble at home and he met with me to
talk about his business and i gave him a
lot of advice he's like oh my god this
is amazing and he's going back home
and he had more follow-up that he wanted
to ask me about and he's got
you know multiple kids at home he's got
his wife they're already on the rocks
like before he left
and
now you know his wife is looking after
the kids well he's on this trip to meet
me and i said you know what the best
thing you can do as you go home now is
don't go home all excited and talking
about how you met me and all the energy
and all these ideas that are coming
because what's going on in her head
in her head is
i've just spent the last x days looking
after all these kids and doing well you
are off having fun there you come right
just like meeting them where they're at
and it feels really counter-intuitive
but the best if you actually want to
serve her the best thing you can do is
just listen to her
and talk about the things that
she cares about
and and don't push
and don't talk about what you're doing
unless she asks
and inside of that ultimately what will
happen is eventually there'll be some
kind of window
you need to eliminate the judgment and
again you are not actually judging her
but she feels judgment
she feels her own insecurity is being
projected from you
and so she attacks
instead of
being open she's not ready yet but she
could be
if she if she doesn't feel the judgment
she feels safe
and then she sees what you're up to
eventually what's going to happen she's
like how are you doing that susan like
how do you how are you
talking about having a healthy routine
like making all these things on your
wall and like now you have confidence in
yourself
right because if you go in and it's
naturally we want to share
if you share here we love you we support
you like you see like
in the chat but if you go back to your
friend who've been known for decades and
say i'm i actually have confidence now
that i've never had ever in my life
she'd be like who does this susan think
she is
[Music]
because your friend doesn't have
confidence
and so it requires being the bigger
person and unless we all have this
whether it's our friends whether it's
our family
the hardest one is if it's your spouse
you know because that's that's a
the inability to grow together i mean
they think that's what ultimately makes
the relationship is like can you grow
together not who you are now but who can
you continue to be ongoing um but
friends and family
is just sitting there being with them
and just spending time with her so she
and now especially if she lost her
father i mean holy she's dealing with
yes i can't imagine losing my dad i mean
it's going to happen at some point but i
can i i don't expect myself to show up
as my most kind empathetic listening
caring person
you know if my dad
yeah thank you actually for saying that
just even just that i mean everything
you said
really really helpful to me
but that last thing about i can't even
imagine you know
you know you're not you can't imagine
how you'd be
i have to keep that i have to keep that
in mind and and really be open to
her
anxiety and her nervousness and her
impatience and
and all of that and i
yeah
i do tend to say too much to her about
what i'm doing because i love to share
with her but i understand your point
it's so much better things that she's
comfortable receiving like be be
cognizant of of and it
it feels
bad to have to dim your own light to be
around friends
and as long as it's not impacting you
negatively like as long as she doesn't
pull you down it's finding connection
points there's hopefully some things you
can talk about that have nothing to do
with the new venture that you're on that
still brings a lot of joy like
um
you know i went to a funeral not too
long ago where
a friend of mine her father passed and
everybody came and uh shared a story
about her father
so like tell me this basically tell me a
story about my dad that i don't know or
even that i do know that you want it so
it became this kind of happy joyful more
of a life celebration because he didn't
want a funeral funeral he wanted like
let's celebrate i don't want everybody
crying here let's make it a life
celebration so
i don't know how well you know the
father but even listening to her
allowing her to like really at this
point her pain
of what she's going through is is way
more than any pain that you're going
through right now
right true so like now it's the role to
go in and just be a supportive friend
and whatever she's feeling she wants to
cry
you'd be a shoulder to cry on if she
wants to talk about her dad and
lessons that um that she learned
you're you're you're listening you're
you're more
just reacting to what's coming from
there this is not your time to go off
and share you want to come here and tell
us
you're on your journey and you're
growing like we're here to listen we
love it she's not ready for that yet you
know and maybe she will never get there
um but baby steps you're like you took
baby steps before you had a big
explosion um
yes
77 years worth
i love it and and not just for you but
again for everybody we all have people
who we wish would be more
understanding and growth oriented and
you learn things and you want to teach
them
all you can do is open the door they
still have to walk through it and they
open the doors you live you live in your
life
and you being with them like continue to
go and build and create and do these
amazing things and then go and just be
with them and sit with them and don't
give any advice until they're asking for
advice
and it will come because
when they don't feel judged and they
feel safe
it will come we'll say how did susan how
did you do this
how did you change it around and that's
when then you can start giving the
advice
thank you so much evan you got it susan
sending lots of love and thank you for
raising your hand really this time and
have a great trip out to see your friend
she's lucky to have you ray what do we
got be real quick with you uh if i cam
because i had like a long story i was
really gonna say but i'd rather just uh
go straight to the point um
i know one of your statements you like
to use is um
make sure that you build a lifestyle and
out of business and so it's something
i've been trying to like put together
myself and been going after this
entrepreneur for
a few years now i've been left my job
pretty much beginning of this year and
kind of like working this full time
um and it just so happened that you know
i pretty much kind of like build up a
skill with copywriting a little bit and
with just advertisements in general so i
was pretty much uh helping different
businesses out with the advertisement
and
uh over
uh i would say
maybe like a month or so ago i started
really doing some search soul searching
because i really want to make some type
of impact or empower some people because
i feel like i'm i feel more fulfilled
helping people out and having
them when they're stuck at a certain
point being able to get them past that
barrier
and um
uh so the weekend just passed we had
like a family gathering and i talked to
different ones and they really had some
really deep conversations and they were
telling me about their situation they
was having and i was giving them some
input and some advice on what they
should do or what options they have
available for them uh even for the young
teenage kids that was pretty much
finished with school and stuff like that
and i felt like um
i was saying
i felt like really good body you know
saying i felt like that fulfillment that
you had while you when i was helping
that person so
i started thinking that maybe i should
go into more coaching instead of like
the consulting side
but i was kind of torn because like i
don't want to step there and jump on
another because i have that syndrome the
shiny object syndrome and i don't want
to jump from business to business to
business when i know there's a lot of
opportunity available so i wanted to ask
the question how would you know
that opportunity is right for you big
decisions with your heart
and small ones with your head
so
you're not jumping to an opportunity
because it sounds good or makes
strategic sense a lot of times that the
heart decisions don't make sense
you know like for you to jump to being a
coach you may say it doesn't make any
sense like i didn't go to school for
this i trained in completely different
skill sets this makes zero sense
but if it's right in your heart you know
you're paying attention to the feeling
like imagine if you could actually be
great at that and how many people you
could serve and help as opposed to we're
not chasing opportunities
it's doing the thing that makes us come
alive
uh
so you know but when you're doing it
it's like how do you know if what's your
favorite food well you have to try a
bunch of stuff how do you know if you
like sushi well you try it and you see
if you like it and does it taste good so
you got a little taste of it this
weekend
and if you don't
chase that down in some capacity you're
going to regret it
you don't want to come back and say man
you know what back in 22 2022 i had this
opportunity and i never did it because i
was i was whatever i was too afraid i
was stuck in my business blah blah blah
it doesn't mean that you shut down your
business and go full time on just being
a coach when you don't know what you're
doing yet but it's spending more time to
pull on that thread to see where it
leads you
oh okay and when you're looking at new
opportunities
it's less of a like the opportunity
lives within like big decisions with
your heart and then you take your head
along with you so
there's lots of opportunities that i
could do
with what i know and skill sets and
connections but it has to be in service
of the mission
so i'm looking for opportunities within
you know on this on the tree that i've
planted
so i want to help entrepreneurs i want
to i want to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough and do that by getting
entrepreneurs making amazing businesses
right
there's lots of opportunities within
that but i care i don't care about
real estate opportunities and crypto
opportunities and like other businesses
that are just outside
of the mission that i'm on
so and and this were built to serve my
help or rereading it but like what is
the mission that you're on
who are the people that you desperately
want to serve that that even right now
may not make financial sense like you
don't know how you're gonna make money
doing it when i first started helping
entrepreneurs
ray i thought i'd never make money doing
it i spoke at an event at a ymca and
three people showed up and it was a free
event
and i said i'm never going to make money
doing this because if i can only get
three people and it's free and the ymca
helped promote this i'm how am i going
to turn into business
i thought as a speaker well who hires
speakers corporations
what corporation's going to hire me to
come and speak like i'm going to go
speak at
at verizon and go tell all their
employees to go become entrepreneurs
like i just didn't think i would ever
i'd never make money doing this
right
but it was in my heart so i had to find
a way to keep going and then use
opportunities and strategy in my brain
to help me figure out how to make it
work
so at the beginning your heart and your
brain are usually not aligned because
your your head your brain wants to keep
you safe and practical and logical and
like i went to school for this and i
have these skill sets so how does that
all map up but there's a problem you
don't love any of the stuff that you're
doing
and the stuff that you love you don't
know how it's gonna
make you any money right yeah and so it
doesn't mean quit everything throw your
business away go all in on coaching and
eventually figure it out like i'm i like
being practical but you you can't just
sit on this thing that you love doing
and and not chase it down so it's how do
you how do you spend time
doing both
to get a taste of this thing
to start building some momentum towards
it to figure out what the opera use your
opportunistic genius mindset
and apply it to the thing that you love
instead of something completely
different
so how can you turn opportunity from
coaching people whether that's
um
actually having them pay you to be a
coach whether that's live speaking on
stage whether you have book deals
whether you're doing deals with big
companies who are sponsoring you like
there's lots of
as soon as you turn your opportunistic
brain
and apply it to the thing that you
actually love doing great things will
open up
it's in the battle of like the judgment
of what do i do because this thing is
paying me and this thing i love
but then we get stuck and you most
people will get stuck on just doing the
thing that pays you
and then you know that like you're not
doing anything that you love and you end
up regretting it like if you look back
and you never spend another day coaching
people you're going to be you're going
to be 77 like susan and say man it's not
too late but i wish i had started back
in 2022.
you're right she's giving double thumbs
up on that one right so i mean you still
got lots of time you know if susan's got
lots of time you got lots of time um
and so if i'm you i try to figure out
you know there's no perfect balance you
know how much time should you spend on
this versus that that's that's a great
question i can't tell you you have to
spend half your time on this and half
your time on that
you likely need to keep making money
from your business right like great well
as long as you don't completely hate it
keep going and building
but you need to spend time on this other
thing and use your opportunistic brain
to then help you build this thing
because this is where the magic is this
is where the money is ultimately this is
where the fulfillment is this is where
the happy life is this is where the
impact is
like if you spent your time on that
thing you're gonna be way happier and
impact way more people and make way more
money than if you continued on the
business that you're currently running
that
it's just okay
you know it may be better than a job
but it's not like
filling your heart
with exploding energy
right gotcha
does that fit yes definitely thank you
so much evan really appreciate it
faith had the winning topic today about
getting a new program launched faith is
in the chat right now actually faith why
don't why don't you uh
tell us quickly what do you like what
are you trying to launch so we can
workshop a little bit more
hello good morning
aloha
um so yes so i um i teach tai chi and
qigong i have for a long time
in person
and i'm putting together an online
school academy
community
to to teach and you know to serve right
i've spent my whole life studying this
and it's like it's time so i'm getting
that together
it's ready
it's actually it's ready i'm i'm well
almost ready i'm ready to go and so
you know it's like and i i do i mean i i
have a plan but then it's like i think
about social media right
and i'm also a photographer so my social
media
you know like i post flowers and stuff
um and so
also to put
that topic into something i can start to
share and put forth to people maybe in
my personal but in my
community group and and really it's just
like getting started like where do i
start to tell people like hey this is
happening
come join me
just okay
who who do we want to be in our
community is it is it people who want to
learn tai chi people want to teach tai
chi like who are the ideal people for
this people who want to learn and
practice tai chi
got it and and it's a course or it's a
membership it's meeting with you once a
week or month or what what do i get if i
join i'm going to have
a couple of different options i'm going
to have live zoom classes
that will meet weekly
okay
recordings will be available to those
students after
so i want to have like that place they
can go and have their references
i'm also going to do some recording
classes so people can have that option
if they just want to do recordings
and then community is such a big thing
that i'm going to also have a community
site where the students can interact
with each other and get support
i know you know i i'm not a tai chi
practitioner my sister was hardcore into
it um how much of it is
practice versus
learning like i mean at the beginning
there's a lot of learning techniques and
the movements and breaking it down how
much of it is
if i'm an intermediate student now how
much of it is like do i get bored in the
beginner class or is it kind of it's
still helpful
uh it is progressive learning
and so as a student goes through the
program the the courses continue so
practice is a big part of it because tai
chi is a practice
and
it's one of the things that
i want to address because if you just go
to class it's not a follow along kind of
a situation right like i really want
people to embody it and take it home and
do it right
but the there'll be an intro class that
will be alive but eventually that intro
is going to go more into a recording
with live support
sort of like what we're doing here
because
as people go once they go through the
intro they're ready for the next course
and they're ready for the next course
but they can't start up here because it
really doesn't make any sense you know
they have to have the building blocks
that's part of the challenge yeah well
there's i mean so you know with every
challenge is an opportunity and um
i just came back from vegas met zayn
there was speaking of event with gary
vee and a bunch of people and uh on my
flight back
i was there early because you never know
like getting to canada there's going to
be delays or whatever and and i got
stopped in the um
the airport lounge he's like evan i saw
you speak at the thing
can i ask you a question say hey grab a
seat and we chatted for 20 minutes
before she went to her plane and she
taught it's similar so she taught guitar
so it's guitar classes not that you know
guitar is tai chi but close you know
we're learning we're teaching something
and it's the same component of like
community plus learning the challenge
that
she faces that you'll face that other
people will face along this journey is
there's there's a certain level of
knowledge people need to be able to do
to be able to practice it
like if you're just starting to teach me
like i don't know where do i put my
hands way where to put my legs what am i
doing right like very basic stuff for
people to figure out
uh which once you learn those basic
things
you kind of don't want to do it again
you know it's like it's kind of boring
to go back and do it again except for
the i come from the salsa dancing world
and they like to say like the beginners
want to learn the intermediate stuff the
intermediates when i learned advanced
stuff and advanced people go back to the
beginning
right it's like to really refine because
you think you got the hand motion but
you don't even know what you're doing
with it so that's like super high level
but most times like the intermediates
don't want to hang out with the
beginners they'll help but it's not
valuable for them as much to learn
anymore
so usually the the best way to do it is
to split it where the first part is a
course
so the foundation of tai chi and teach
me how to do the basic motions
so that or movements or whatever
whatever it's called
so that i'm ready to go to
the group practice
so there's there's
it's either a course or like a boot camp
where you're doing it live with them but
there's a start and an end and it's a
fixed state it's like i will teach you
how to do tai chi inside of eight weeks
or
or
whatever 20 weeks 16 weeks four weeks
however long it takes you to do it right
but you have people start together or
it's a course where it's evergreen and
they're following along so that when
they get to the community side of things
if it's a weekly practice that you're
doing
like hey join me every day at 9 00 a.m
pacific or whatever and we're going to
go do tai chi together it's less
instruction of how to do it and more
just community of us doing it together
does that make sense
um
and then on top of that you could sell
more private one-on-one of like how do i
how do i really master
that move or how do i use tai chi
with my
hip that's hurting me or how to it's
like all sorts of different custom
things that people then ask like
you know they want to go deeper and so
that's when you sell the one-on-one at a
higher level so there's there's course
or boot camp
at the beginning
it's just basically planning for the
fact that the beginners will get to the
intermediates and the intermediates will
start to get bored and so they're not
all mixed into the same group
right
so boot camp or or or workshops or
or course
teach it in eight weeks then it goes to
the community side where and they paint
like
less teaching but just more community
and every it could also be people who
you have who lead this it's not always
you who has to lead it it could be a
daily thing
every day like as you build and scale
and grow every day there's a new
there's a new tai chi community thing to
do it together like in our park here
people go and do tai chi every morning
and it's a community
thing where
they run through the same sequence
together even if they haven't met each
other
right like if i
my sister could go and meet other people
i've never met before and they just they
know how to do the same motions in the
park together
um so now i don't have to practice by
myself now i've got this zoom community
people to do it
uh and then you're the you're
you're the top or you're the queen or
you're the head um and if people want
more one-on-one access then that's what
they go to you for
how does that sit
yes that that sits great and actually
lines up with what i was thinking in
terms of bringing people in in the
progression because you can't yeah
you've got to progress them and you
can't mix them and that's that's sort of
always the challenge so
one question related to that right as we
talk about social media and this can
apply for anything that we're putting
forth right and like posting and you
know content and all of that
do you have any suggestion on how to
you know like do you just put little
quotes or like
like i don't really know how to do the
social media part and start to to
propagate that
to you know kind of bring people into
the
whole thing
yeah so okay let me let me pull up your
account and then we can we can
we can dissect it together here get some
feedback
so is this it this is the one
uh
no that's my instagram photography thing
that i don't really do anything with
i have i don't have a handle on
instagram
oh okay cool well
so
anyway but you know what this is a good
indication of like what i normally do
well cool but that's not that's that's
next right so you know your founder of
your school awesome it's this tai chi
you got cool awesome um whether you want
to update this one to become the brand
or we're going to launch a new one for
the brand
in terms of making content
everything can work i mean we're seeing
the biggest success right now with reels
i talked about that mover makers a few
times but reels are performing just
insanely well super short clips um and
obviously we need we need to talk about
tai chi we need i mean it's great to
have flowers and stuff but we need to
talk about tai chi on our on our tai chi
account that people know that they can
get access to you and what you're up to
and the value of tai chi and what is
we're targeting beginners like what is
tai chi how can it help you
how has it helped you know you
personally how has it helped the
students in your class not as a sales
pitch but but value-add and a good
indication of type of content to make is
look at the people who you're following
so let's see who you're following so if
i click on who you're following evan
carmichael okay good i follow i follow
personal development coaches only and a
few photographers on my instagram no but
that's good like if you look at these
people
you you take like you follow them for a
reason they make you feel something they
make you feel a certain way you know you
love their message
you know you're following tom and jamie
and mel and and other mel and anthony
and i mean these are all my friends this
is great
um
so what is a what is it about then that
makes you
want to follow them and whose content
are you like most engaged with and and
your job was to take and capture some of
that feeling
but put it inside the world of tai chi
so your message isn't that
off from amel robbins or jamie kern lima
just the packaging is through tai chi
instead of a speech
does that make sense
yes
am i am i am i too out there like
talking
and really when i when i look at you
know what they're putting forth right
it's yeah it's good i mean my instagram
is sort of like when i scroll it it's
sort of like personal development 101.
um and that's fine and that's what you
do like tai chi is person development
it is yes it's just not through speeches
it's through motion
right right it's like people people
leave
me aside and my sister like to come out
more confident more
more self-aware
more um more self-belief more connected
like all all of the benefits that you
get from personal development just
you're teaching it through motion as
opposed to you getting on stage and
and speaking or writing the book
personal development and tai chi are not
like
two totally separate entities
you're you're accomplishing the same
thing just through different different
ways
so that's the point like if you take of
who you love about personal development
and and then
take that part and throw it into
tai chi
so we're talking about how to or we're
showing how to have more
belief or self-awareness to self-respect
through the motion of tai chi i wouldn't
stress out too much about having the
perfect picture perfect video or
anything yet
um just get started because you don't
have you haven't started on that new
account yet or transition your account
um
but yeah if you can mix that like
personal development that you love
mix it with tai chi
and
that gives birth to you know the content
that's how you start to post content
that's gonna win
okay that's
really helpful thank you thank you
it's a weird thing to say that personal
development is tai chi you know like
that like they're we're both getting
into this but it is
it is
no it is you're right i love that so you
have to capture the essence of person
development mix it with tai chi and now
we've got special faith brand that
nobody else can can match awesome thank
you for that thank you so much
the leading poll this time was how to
start a successful online business i
think it just starts with figuring out
what are you selling
and and when you start with what you're
selling you go to the next level of how
can you start selling something to make
money faster
uh a lot of people when they're starting
they're selling
something that takes way too long to get
going
i think people
take too long to start making money and
when you're not making money it's hard
to keep going on your dream when nothing
is coming in
and so what's the fastest path to start
making more money so finding a faster
way to get started with with the thing
that you're selling so that i can make
money more quickly and that's where
usually it's some kind of service i'm a
big fan of starting with a service over
a product
because products take time to be able to
make
and i want you making money faster so
what can you do at the beginning to
to yes trade your time for money because
you're trading if you're at a job or
doing something else you're trading your
time for money there i'd rather trade my
time for money doing something i love
and helping people
which then also allows you to make
better products and services like built
to serve the book
i don't even have it on me here um
how do you write a good book
built a serve
i wrote pretty
quickly uh
i wrote a third of the book
on a 16-hour drive to and from new york
with a broken neck
while nina was driving
because i had to get to new york and i
broke my neck and i couldn't fly they
wouldn't let me on a plane because of
the pressure would
impact my neck so we had to drive there
it's like eight eight nine hours from
toronto and nina drove and i wrote
a third of the book in the car sitting
next to her there's a section in the
book where i say this is kind of weird
to write because nina's right now i was
talking about nina and she's right next
to me like this is a weird part to write
because she's right next to me as i'm
typing this out
i could write it that quickly because of
all the work that i had done to help
people
so a book a great nonfiction book where
you're giving advice is basically
coaching at scale
without any feedback
same thing speaking on stage is coaching
at scale without a lot of feedback when
you're coaching somebody and you tell
them something give them some advice
they give you some kind of rebuttal they
you feel like where they're struggling
you can get a lot more personal but when
it's in a book they're still thinking
the same thing but they
they're not telling you when you're
creating the course same thing
when you're speaking same thing and so
before going to a book or course or
speech
i'm a much bigger fan of doing the work
to help people so that you know what
their resistances are you know what the
feedback is going to be that then when
you move to a bigger audience
you can already address most of those
issues because you've done it so much
before in the one-on-ones so i think it
i think it doing a service first pays
you immediately which is awesome and
also helps you make better products and
services because you've got
more experience in helping people so
that was a topic of the day uh now
usually we throw it over q a whatever
you got for me this little reactions
thing at the bottom that you can use if
you click on the reactions face you can
then raise your hand
and we'll bring people up just we'll
unmute you and ask your question and try
to help as much as possible
tanya
she was on she was on front stage at the
build to surf challenge that was fun
i want to
to to to i don't know if the world is
correct i want to launch a course
because i already have the experience i
know
i mean i know
what to what would be useful for for
people and discuss in this case
international students i know how to
help them to you know through the whole
process of from
starting from their countries to get
here to canada i know all that
like i know that i have the experience
i've been doing it for so many years 14
years so i know that but i don't know
how to make it attractive like
the structure and how to launch it
that's the part that it's kind of like
uh
you know uh detaining me from from
finally put this uh
everything in place and being able to
launch and to and to
and to put the course together yeah so
i mean you could do it through videos
you could do it through pdfs you could
do it through powerpoints you can give
people part of it also like the forms
and how to fill out the forms
right if you're trying to get into
canada what are the forms that people
need to fill out and give them the
templates so that they can do it right
and i think if you can position it as
the education and the experience
that you've
like you know how to get it done so that
you have the wisdom
plus the templates here's how you
because those government forms are
terrible it's like none of them make any
sense right but i wouldn't be
directed into the immigration party
because that's very it's very too much
liability and it changes a lot so it is
hard to to to coach a distance about
that i wouldn't go that way i would i
would be more interested or i think that
it would be more useful to create what
you were saying today in the morning
something that it's not limited by time
like something that is gonna be good now
and and maybe five years later it's
because
laws change too much immigration law
changes too much
so it wouldn't be that good idea to
focus in the immigration part i would
create and my thinking is create a
chapter about immigration like
immigration 101 kind of like give them
an initial insight about it but make it
more about education and the process of
of of you know deciding and starting and
finally going through the process of
selecting a school what's best uh what
type of education they are looking for
like guide them through
um from the beginning to the end till
they you know find the school and they
get to canada uh but more from the
education point this time or point of
view so i mean the reality with any
course is it will need to have some
updating
because even in
even in the the only thing that wouldn't
be updated is if you're talking you know
mindset or belief or any of the person
development stuff but if you're helping
pick between schools like which school
am i going to go to even if we're
ignoring immigration which school do you
pick
well things might change about the
school or a school might go out of
business or a school might merge with
another school or
you know
that so you you have to
think about
you'll be updating the course probably
once a year as a commitment
yeah that would be okay it's terrible
but so even in that then like if you can
package the wisdom to know because
you've done it and you have the
experience with the templates so even if
the templates are not going to be
government related
you still have to apply to the school
you still have to fill out different you
know so like the more that you can have
done for you stuff in there as well that
they can copy and paste
and walk through
it's just an extra layer on top of
just the wisdom
and then if we talk if you circle back
to what we talked about on the build to
serve challenge
with
the concept of love and and helping um
educate
latin american women uh mothers latin
american mothers was it
uh yeah they yeah that would be my ideal
group like mothers with children and uh
that are in a
situation that
they
would need some skill
to move forward like some additional
skills to move forward and that would be
language english
so a part of that is hey by buying your
package i also can support a class
that's good
that's great it's not the whole thing
but it's it's a nice add-on that hey if
i buy your course if i spend however
much money to buy your course
it also helps me buy
a class to help
30 mothers in latin america learn some
english to improve their skills
this week
right
that's how you stand out as your your
business and then and then so that's the
like that's the
that's the course you have your course
with either videos or pdfs or
powerpoints
then you have your templates that they
can fill out that you guide them through
the process of how to fill it out or
create your own templates for you know
we have a built to serve this to build
certain book but there's also the
worksheets that go with the book okay so
yeah so that's a template like i'm
creating a template for people because
there's the book but then hey
here are these sheets that you can help
fill out we'll guide you through how to
do it
so what are the templates that people
can have in addition to the wisdom and
then if they feel like they're
connecting to
bigger it's not just about them but
they're also helping mothers in latin
america learn english to
get you know more freedom for themselves
that's the
that's the cherry on top
um that's nice thank you so that's what
i would look at for the course and then
promoting it
it's content and also
who can help you promote it you know who
who is talking to these students
before they did make this decision
that they might
help make introductions for you uh maybe
even take a referral fee for them making
those introductions
mm-hmm
okay thank you very much thank you good
luck
beirut um is it barrett gosh i'm gonna
say your name would you please ask evan
a question
i don't know he put people on the spot
but he's been chatting with me behind
the scenes but like no talk to evan yeah
what i wanted to do is i actually wanted
to learn more about xan services so i'll
connect with him um through instagram
but what i'm looking to do is is try to
get some more insight on um
a new role that i'm going to be playing
um at a
at a startup so that's why i thought
maybe it might be helpful more with
yourself it's not to do with blogging or
anything it's part of an accelerator
program
so a little bit of that is is getting
out of my comfort level and and being
exposed to startups but further wanted
to learn you know kind of i've read the
book
and
kind of need a little bit more help in
terms of being able to structure my
career path
i'd say and and understand how i can be
of service to these institutions
based on the experience i've have
with 20 plus years in
real estate and what i'm going into is
real estate technology startups
cool that's one question that's kind of
come up to my in my head so what are you
doing at the incubator
i'm assisting um i'm actually co-running
it
oh cool
yeah it's with dmz in in our
neighborhood in toronto oh you're in
toronto cool out of uh out of uh
ryerson well i don't even know what they
call themselves now but yeah ryerson
yeah it's not ryerson anymore yeah
metropolitan university or university or
something yeah and so is that what you
want to do you want to like go co-found
more
i'd like to i'd like to um this is
something new and you know opportunities
came about and something i've been
working on
and it's taken about two years to be
able to find a venture vc to
um
go back this and we're going to be
starting up uh in september i'm going to
be visiting the office later today
but that's something where i thought i
would be able to try to find out if i
can get some help from zan or from you
just in terms of understanding
again how can i make an impact because a
lot of things you're seeing are
are really coming into into play here in
terms of being able to provide a service
and making sure that i have the
opportunity to grow
and learn in that role
if that makes any sense
yeah
most incubators don't work
yeah and most companies at incubators
don't work
and so
if you're looking for like next stage in
life and what to do after like that if
you make it work you'll have unlimited
opportunities
to to join other incubators to start new
incubators the key is like make this one
thing work
right for the entrepreneurs coming in
they struggle with
um the biggest thing they struggle with
is closing sales like they struggle with
getting their product depending on what
stage but usually it's in incubators
it's early stage it's early stage yeah
so like yeah it's one getting getting
their mvp getting their middle viable
product
like created and then bringing in
revenue
the businesses shut down because they
can't generate sustainable cash flow
right so right you know if you're in
real estate you understand the cash and
sales yeah and try to utilize the
network because what you're saying yeah
so so helping them get to the point
where they're at least covering their
costs so that they can hang around long
enough to blow up like so many
entrepreneurs are focused on i'm going
to go change the world with my new tech
startup cool yeah
let's get to the point where you can
stay sustainable
right what's what are those first sales
that we need to bring in and whether
that's you making introductions
to people
it's a big reason why people would join
an incubator right you're going to
introduce them to somebody that's going
to help
or if you're going to just stay on them
and train them like helping them with
their pitch
helping them with their decks helping
them on the phone helping them do the
follow-ups
helping them become salespeople a lot of
tech startups suck at sales because
they're yeah that's what i'm finding
you know but they did enough to get into
into the incubator so they sold
themselves enough to get in there so
they've got something
but it's that combination of of the
training to do better sales um even the
accountability like if you
if you uh help them stay entrepreneurs
suck with accountability
right yeah so
like they say they're gonna do something
and they don't do it see evan
um or are you saying that's me i don't
know
no no i'm writing this down now i wanna
haven't put his hand up um but
entrepreneurs stuck with accountability
especially at the beginning where they
have no idea then this is their first
thing so
helping them with that like coming in
and setting what's what's our sales plan
guys
what's our what
what's our sales plan
yeah
right and then helping them actually
create one and stick to it and making
sure that they're doing the thing that
they said they were going to do not just
going into the tech that they love
geeking out over and you helping make
introductions for them
allows them to have success which then
allows the incubator to have success
which then allows you to go wherever you
want to go afterwards
got it yeah it's helpful i appreciate
that
um
there's the whole motivation side to
like you bring in guest speakers and all
that kind of stuff but really it's like
get them get them to a sustainable
business and then get them to to going
off and changing the world
and and sales playing and uh
introductions
so like for every business identified
their ideal clients and then yeah your
network and also friends of friends who
might be able to come in
and either buy from them or at least
give them honest feedback of where
they're falling down like people will
take a meeting because they love
supporting
the the university and they love
supporting incubators right take the
meeting if you reach out and it may not
become a client but at least you get
really good feedback
and they may not know how to do that so
if you spent you know
half an hour a week with everybody
trying to help them
make those introductions
some of those will hit and you'll end up
really having a lot of success there and
then that's it you just have to make
that one work
and then you could be the incubator guru
and go around the world doing it like
most of them fail so yeah the guy who
says so in this one it's interesting
because i've got we're being backed up
by um a large pension fund
so that's going to be a bit of a live
case study in terms of the companies or
two or three companies that we choose
out of that incubator to work on lean on
them
okay lean on the investors to say hey
we've got a tech startup inside
computer peripherals or whatever we need
we need to get to these guys like every
company in their sales plan that comes
through you needs to make a list of
their top 50 clients that they want to
talk to and you might know some of them
already cool and if not you lean on you
talk to the pension fund hey we need to
talk to whoever's in charge of tech at
royal bank
do you know anybody
yeah okay got it yeah i know where you
come from is there anything that you
recommend i i read any of your material
or anything in terms of
because this is kind of really pretty
much what you are doing in terms of
helping the startups as well
um
i don't have a lot of good books to
wreck i don't really read a lot of books
i mean build a server is great
got it yeah i've got that so that's a
good one required reading at the
incubator
um but honestly it's just
you just have to be a resource for them
like help them get sales
like if they're coming in they probably
already have a mission and they're
probably working on their tech but how
do they
commercialize this and if you have
big uh like the pension fund that's
involved in your thing cool they're
investing into tons of companies
like the amount they're investing in you
is so small compared to their entire
portfolio the problem is most people
are not most of their portfolios are not
reaching out asking for help
and they have a deep network of people
so you reach out and say hey we need to
get to
whoever runs tech at royal bank to get
feedback on this can you help us
yeah i hear you saying leverage dmz's
resources to our advantage and network
yeah like the resources as a network
yeah exactly
the tech guys need to know the like the
com the startup companies need to know
how to create their thing
create the product or service but right
the network to get it into the hands so
it's commercializable that needs to be
pulling on dmz pulling on all the
investors and that could be you to help
be the liaison for that
and maybe they say no cool
but most people aren't even asking
yeah yeah you're right no
i appreciate it yeah
cool thank you
you got it
um
marie thank you zen
there you go
but you know what this is very meta this
is very matter like what zen just did
here it you were acting like most of the
companies in your incubator act
yep you're right hidden camera off not
asking questions but needing help for
like that's everybody who's coming
through your company
they don't want to turn the camera on
and ask for help and and talk about
their business because they'd rather
just stay tinkering and attack
and what zen said like hey come on and
ask this question
and hopefully you get no it i could have
not picked you i could have said no
screw this guy without his camera on i
could have like not given you good
advice but at least you took the shot
right yeah i know i agree so you need to
be the zen for everybody who comes in
and help open up even if like zan didn't
have the answer to this question he
would have answered some other way but
the way he didn't have the answer but he
facilitated the connection that's all
you need to do
you may not have the answer to who runs
tech at world bank but you can
facilitate the connection with these
people so that they can start to grow
got it it's awesome thank you
thanks man there you go thank you zan
that's what it's all about
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love